today we have gary tam the co-founder of
initialize capital
just had a gigantic win with coinbase's
ipo how much did
money did you make on that deal roughly
for my investors we made
you know about two billion dollars or so
how does that feel
i mean it's awesome and if anything i'm
like i want to do that over and over
again and the cool thing is that's what
venture capital actually is like the
whole point of it
is this kind of stuff like find the next
google find the next coinbase i want the
stuff i put together
to actually help people go and start
businesses people look at technology
it's like you have to have a stanford
degree in cs
to like start a company and i'm like no
that's not actually how it should work
it might work like that
20 years ago but it's not how it works
today i don't want it to work that way
the good news is that there is an
organic way to
understand everything that you need to
know to start a business
and to get ahead in life we're on that
side of the equation
right and then there's another darker
side that
requires the people to enter that side
to charge money
and charge a lot of money and then the
tricky thing
that's funny is that like i actually
don't think that they're good businesses
don't do it for the money do it because
like you get to create something that's
awesome
and then it might be something that a
billion people end up using which is
insane
but first gary thank you so much for
coming on the show
thank you for having me this is super
fun big fan long time
long time watcher viewer thank you thank
you so much
so i think obviously the huge news is uh
coinbase
ipo'd and how much did money did you
make on that deal roughly
oh uh for my investors we made
you know about two billion dollars or so
and uh off of less than three hundred
thousand dollars in
so how does that feel i mean it's
awesome and
yeah if anything i'm like i want to do
that over and over again
and the cool thing is that's what
venture capital actually is like the
whole point of it
is this kind of stuff like find the next
google find the next coin base and
when you hit you hit like outrageously
big
and it's awesome so obviously
hindsight's 20 20.
but did you feel like when you found
coinbase can you tell us a little bit
about
finding did you first meet brian or who
who did you first meet
and did you feel like you know i mean
obviously there's always going to be a
hindsight bias but did you
what made coinbase attractive to you
starting out
yeah so i i got introduced to brian
through another founder who had backed
he now actually founded a billion dollar
company
called sift science so it just recently
reached a billion
wow uh you know and coinbase uh
you know top ticked at 100 billion so
that's the crazy thing about tech right
like when business
works you know you can literally have
these giant swings of
a thou you know a hundred x a thousand x
like ten thousand x
um but you know at that point it was you
know i'm a software engineer
that other founder was a software
engineer and brian was a software
engineer
and that's actually sort of what brought
us together it was like i knew that
brian
with jason tan from sift science were
working together brian was at airbnb at
the time
as a you know actually as an engineer
just implementing anti-fraud technology
and jason said hey my best customer he's
starting a company
but you know he's so amazing he would
stay up until 2am with us
when he didn't have to like this was you
know above and beyond
like a normal software engineering job
even at like a high
high powered startup like airbnb it's
like who stays up until 2am for your
employer
but i think that was what really jumped
out at me
was like this is someone who is doing it
for the love of actually making stuff
and you know it sounds like that
shouldn't happen but that was actually
how
we found and funded someone like brian
armstrong
it was that he was true engineer hacker
wanted to create stuff uh you know for
real like not doing it for the money
which is crazy because you go to a you
hear these speeches about like follow
your passion
and all of that but that's that's what i
think is really really true for people
who are you know are starting out in
their careers in particular
it's like don't do it for the money do
it because like you get to create
something that's awesome
and then it might be something that a
billion people end up using which is
insane
i find that so interesting that you kind
of invested in him
for who he was or at least you got
interested in at first with who he was
that's something that i've heard jason
calcanis says he goes i
invest in the person almost as much or
more than i invest in the company itself
um because there is no company right
yeah right
especially yeah yeah it's an idea it's
an idea and
really it's all most of its execution at
that point
when did you sort of get a picture of
what
he wanted to do with crypto well so i
had tried to buy bitcoin on mount gox
you know i was curious like anyone else
um
i thought you know this is a crazy idea
it might just work and let me try to buy
it and
it was like literally going to a magic
the gathering trading card
forum and trying to buy something that
felt completely illicit
it wasn't clear that the credits would
ever show up and what felt like
basically a php pv website and it did
and i ended up getting the bitcoin
and then the lucky thing is i funded
coinbase so i was able to transfer the
bitcoin off of the exchange onto
coinbase
and that's how i kept my bitcoin before
it blew up because yeah people yeah
totally
mount gox for those who don't know
completely blew up a lot of people lost
all their money everything yeah all of
their bitcoin
that's kind of funny because that is to
some extent
like that's coinbase's niche is that
we're the
you might think the most legitimate um
crypto exchange like and they also will
let place for your bitcoin
yeah right exactly um i i when i first
got into crypto
my first account was with coinbase
because i looked i looked around i said
this is sort of a intimidating new
technology i don't know where to go
who's got sort of the easiest interface
to go to
i think brian has done a great job of
positioning himself
within that market do you know i don't
know of how much you talked to them
early on um do you know if they've
intended to do that from the get-go
of like yeah this is our positioning and
they had to i mean i think brian the
cool thing about him is that he's so
first principles
he's like well let me work backwards
from the world i want to live in which
is i want to be able to use bitcoin to
pay my rent to buy a pizza to do
you know all these things ended up
happening over coinbase but um
you know you couldn't really do it in
order to transfer bitcoin from one
person to another
you would have to download a client
download a full node
learn how to use a command line tool and
then even then like who on the other end
is actually going to be able to do that
and receive that bitcoin
and so he sort of worked backwards from
i want i know that i want to use bitcoin
for everything
and then what do what do i need to do to
get there
and then he built it that's amazing just
as an aside before we move on
um are you a bitcoin maximalist do you
believe in other coins
what sort of your uh do you got any hot
takes about crypto
oh yeah i mean i love bitcoin i hold
bitcoin if anything
that's the main thing that's sort of
driving the revolution right now is
people
uh look at the amount of u.s dollars in
the world and 25 percent of all us
dollars were printed in the last year
so that's made up right you know money
printers are going burr
and you want a safe place to store money
so
that makes sense to me but the next
generation i think is really about
defy and maybe marketplaces and
decentralized autonomous organizations
and that requires programmable money and
that's what ethereum actually is
and it might be ethereum i actually
think solana might be really good
um but there's something like that you
know there are a bunch of different
chains
that um you know we could mention it you
know polka dot i think is interesting
um but you know i'm mainly only holding
ethereum and
bitcoin because those i think are sort
of the home base like
all roads sort of like lead back to
those
yeah and i do i i agree i agree i'm
kind of similar um and if you're i think
right now
unfortunately sorry everyone it's a scam
don't do it people are gonna cancel me
for this
but i would not tell my closest friends
to buy doge right now
well the whole reason i mean you just
look at why most people are buying it
most people are buying it because other
people are buying it if we can just get
everyone to buy it
the price go up yeah i mean it's
nihilism
it's we have i'm not a nihilist i can't
deal with that
i didn't buy gamestop i bought coinbase
well you did very well for yourself uh
and for your investors two billion
dollars
that has to be one of the biggest wins
in venture capital i mean
i imagine like in terms of your your ex
that is
that is like an all-time great
investment not yet i mean we're lucky
we're lucky
yeah it's amazing let's do more so one
of the things you talk
you talk about in terms of if we could
get into the mind of
how you invest because you know coinbase
came came and went you can't invest in
coinbase at the start anymore
when if people are thinking about um
investing in new companies and we should
say that it's very risky
and that you should make sure that you
can lose that money because venture
capital as you said is just trying to
find that one home run
you talk about something called pre-fit
you invest in products pre-fit
what is that yeah so uh
product market fit is sort of what
everyone's looking for
um it's literally you've made something
that people really want and they want it
so much
that you suddenly look down and all of
your graphs are up into the left
you know there are up and to the right
they are just completely
you know going up all the time you're
running out of
inventory you're running out of people
to do customer support
like you're just trying to hold it
together really and
um that was the moment it wasn't when i
first invested in coinbase coinbase
spent at least
nine to 12 months sort of in the
wilderness you know bitcoin was up
it was down uh people weren't really
paying attention to this
they were still using mount gox uh but
then at some point
everything shifted i think it was a mix
of you know
google decided to bless coinbase as the
number one hit in
when you search for bitcoin um i think
it was
bitcoin itself went from five bucks to
20 bucks on the way to two thousand
dollars
and so it was a confluence of forces
and you know brian armstrong was right
software
right place right time to capitalize and
build the brand
and so it's basically part luck
and part preparation and the only thing
you can do is preparation
so you're in if i understand
you're trying to find founders before
they've kind of found their way
necessarily yeah
yeah or even that there's a market yet
how do you even do that though i mean
that seems like
like like venture capital already feels
like throwing a dart at a dartboard
blind
this feels like throwing a dart and you
don't even know if there's a dartboard
there
yeah well i was sort of primed for
bitcoin as an idea
because i worked for peter thiel uh
making hedge fund software for him
and they made me read this book called
the dollar crisis so all the things we
talk about today
where the u.s dollar is a fiat currency
and anyone can you know the fed just
prints it all the time
that wasn't something that people
generally knew um you know you can trace
everything back to that moment when
nixon took us off the dollar
the gold standard and you know uh
your wtf happened in 1971.com right just
go to that website and you'll see
there's no commentary it's just graphs
of everything about modern society
changed at that moment
and so i had that loaded in my head and
then i had actually tried mount gox
so if i connected those things together
i said
well this is a fringe weird thing but
smart people who
can build stuff have already invested
their time and energy in this thing
and so if i say that what they believe
actually comes true what will this be
and
you know at that moment i said this is
it
like this has to be it um but the thing
is and
you're right to point out like this is
uh
you know we had to fund 98 other
companies
that all didn't do that well i'll take
it back
probably 20 of them did well enough to
make their founders millionaires
but you know probably 80 of them
basically went out of business
and um you know that that isn't to say
we didn't make money
we sometimes got our money back and that
isn't to say the founders didn't end up
better like not all of them uh ended up
better off but many of them went on and
got better jobs like became
head of you know tech or you know pm at
all these other top companies
so you know the cool thing about it is
like even in failure
if you're good and you're a good builder
you can actually still succeed
but then it still definitely took a
portfolio of a hundred companies
you know about fifty thousand dollars in
a hundred companies
in order for us to find two companies
worth ten billion dollars or more the
other one in that portfolio of a seven
million dollar fund
was instacart actually wow that
that's really exciting and to be to do
the math for everybody that's five
million dollars
most of which you i mean presumably
would it would have taken and taken a
loss on
to find those two wins but part of i
guess
uh finding finding a company before the
product market fit
is that you have less competition i
would assume from other venture
capitalists who
are looking for that right i mean i
don't think people were looking for
something like coinbase at the moment
that we funded it when brian armstrong
was one person
um because oh you know actually after
series a
after that moment when bitcoin went off
five to twenty dollars
after they raised their first series a
from union square ventures that was when
suddenly
there were crypto funds and there were
people looking for that thesis and
what's funny is there were probably two
dozen different
competitors to coinbase that were funded
after coinbase
but coinbase already was number one in
google like you couldn't unseat them at
that point
like it already it was already doing 15
of the global volume of bitcoin
um transactions on mount gox so it was
already
it had already won and uh all of those
other
uh bitcoin sort of like fast follower
coinbase competitors i think 90
of them died that's incredible how
how much sometimes tech can can can be
that way about having
being at the right place at the right
time having the right foundation
sort of getting there early but i think
you also have to have
a vision right like over and over it
just seems like the people who
understand the thesis
first are best positioned to move
what thesis do you see do you understand
now or do you believe in now that you
don't think
most other people have caught on to yet
oh man that's a great question
i think people well the hard part is
asking a vc this
is uh is not on the cutting edge
enough because the the true answer to
that
is sitting in the mind of a founder
who's watching this right now
and they won't know whether or not it's
the thing that will be the future yet
until they try to convince someone else
of it and then if they can convince that
other
person then uh you know that's two
people who will go out and come you know
infect like four people and then these
things like sort of spread like viruses
after that
you know crypto itself is like the
perfect manifestation of a mind virus
and the cool thing is you know any it
can come from any of us
so i don't know i have like a bunch of
different weird themes though that
i think are you know continuing to grow
really quickly i mean i think
the idea that computers can see right
now that's insane
you know that's why we were the first
investors in cruise automation
which was the first commercialized oh
yeah uh attempted an
uh autonomous vehicle company you know
before it was google x
and it was a research project and they
probably never were going to ship
anything
but crews came along and said oh no
we're actually going to retrofit some
audi s4s on this one and
try to get some stuff on the road yeah
let's get stuff on the road
and i think that taught us that you know
the ability for computers to be able to
see
and recognize things uh i mean
it's wild like we're just at the very
early part of that
and so if you're a software engineer you
learn machine learning and computer
vision
like you could just i mean that's that's
the future of all robotics
i mean god help us maybe we'll all be
out of jobs
but but that's where it's gonna go
it's almost too obvious now maybe but i
i but i agree i i do
think that has like a really promising
future i think
um biotech's exciting but moving on from
venture capital this is sort of part of
part of
gary tan another part of you is near and
dear to my heart you're a youtuber like
like a real deal you put a ton of time
into youtube you have a youtube channel
we'll link it right here guys go
subscribe where you
do what i've been you found the product
market fit that i've been looking for
which is
qualified people talking about business
and giving
advice to young entrepreneurs young
business people but you've actually
done it yourself what got you inspired
to do that
i mean honestly i started uh
in the same way that a lot of other
people start which is uh casey neistat
strangely i met casey you know
incredible person
uh but what really got me was um he uh
walked into our office and initialized
and
uh how our 20 year old interns
interacted with him got me thinking
because they walked up to him
and they were like it was like seeing an
old friend and then casey actually just
went
into it and he was like oh you know this
like happens to him like 10 000 times a
day i'm sure he's like
oh hey it's like he just goes with it
he's like i'm just talking with my old
friend who i
have spent you know 50 hours with over
the past couple years
after i saw that then i watched all 50
hours or
whatever it is like you know hundreds of
hours of casey's stuff
and then now casey is a character in my
head because
i feel like i know him even though i
don't really you know
and um then i realized oh all of human
consciousness is actually switching up
right now
and this parasocial dynamic of people
being able to talk to each other
that is so powerful and you can use it
for good well you can
and this i think is what is relevant to
you because you can use it for good or
you can use it for evil
and so i desperately want to use this
power for good because
i want to spread the good news like i
want to spread the gospel
you know like we meet people who are
software
engineers who are not different than
like the people who are watching this
channel right now
and you know but they do sit down in
front of a computer and they ship code
that like touches 10 people and 100
people and 1 000 people and then like a
billion people
and that's like the world that we live
in that's the good news right and i want
people to do that
but there are other people who are like
check out my crazy paddock felipe watch
and like i'm driving a lambo
knowledge yeah exactly well
i think i i think you said it best
there's a powerful shift going on which
is that the new
kind of influencer or whatever does
build
it builds altitude for one thing i mean
like when you go
when casey neistat walked into your
office he had immediate rapport
in a way that almost no one else has
ever had before even
celebrities i mean even you know more
and more we're seeing in the lives of
celebrities but for a while is like oh
they're just on the movie
you wouldn't see you know dwayne the
rock johnson and think i know that guy
you would think oh there's a star but
you wouldn't think i know him
whereas now all these influencers you do
think you know
something about them depending on how
intimate they let you in their life
and i do think it is a really powerful
tool
for connecting with people um and sort
of taking
whatever you want to take to the next
level as you said it can take
fraud fake gurus whatever to the next
level it can also take
you know uh venture capital people to
the next level and introduce them to all
sorts of
new founders that may have found you
unapproachable before right like
they think oh that's the guy who
invested in coinbase he's never gonna
invest in me right
but um but like if they see oh it's gary
it's gary from the youtube show i'll
i'll go hit him up
or whatever um i agree it's really
powerful
what are some lessons you've learned as
a new youtuber like going from like
you know mostly focusing on a business
now you're on like a social side have
you noticed anything different
oh man i mean i find that i want
everyone i know who's smart
who could influence people to do this
now do you ever do that do you ever
convince your friends to try to become
youtubers now that you have done it
yeah well because like here's some power
that is like maybe really useful for you
but like and then generally i try and do
it with people who i genuinely think
like could help other people
that's what i try to do so so i've
stopped doing it when you
when i first kind of got a little bit um
figured out youtube a little bit i was
like i wanted to help everyone do it but
then i realized
there's so much survivorship bias in
this thing that it's a bit like
have you ever heard that do you know
that what the joe rogan podcast is i
mean i
yeah of yeah so he's always telling
everyone they need to start a podcast
and at a certain point it becomes a
little bit grading you're like joe not
everybody's gonna start like
this gigantic podcast some people get
like five viewers whatever
so i try to not be that like i'm like i
wanna encourage the people that i think
this person not in other words not fit a
circle into the square peg hole right
like but instead fit somebody who like
it seems like no they've got they have
something they want to say a
and b they look like they have the
stomach for the long grind
because it is a long grind to really
crazy reap the results
how long have you been doing it a year
right uh yeah just on
coming up on two years now but yeah it's
wild how many subscribers are you at uh
i think i'm at 125. something
you're killing yeah gary yeah
i'm blessed man like i'm very lucky so i
have no complaints you know
i but i'm excited because i'm like i
want this i want the stuff i put
together to actually help people go and
start businesses
and i think that that's kind of already
happening and so i think the next step
for me is like i want to create a
community
that's built on the people who sort of
watch my stuff
actually and who are like building
things hopefully
yeah exactly and then if we can go and i
feel like you know
i i tend to think about this in terms of
like how do i how do we build
uh the catholic church it's like how do
we build something
i've noticed this religious theme with
uh computer science you're like you're
like
the good news catholic church
it's weird right but like that that's
what i'm trying that's the
that's the wavelength i'm on right now
because i want people to know that they
have a hand in this
actually because you know it's scary
these days like people look at
technology
and they say i can't you know it's like
you have to have a stanford degree
in cs to like start a company and i'm
like no that's not actually how it
should work
it might work like that 20 years ago but
it's not how it works today i don't want
it to work that way
right like what matters is can you make
something that's awesome
and then can we evaluate it on the terms
of that instead of like someone's stupid
resume right like
the world is so unjust when it comes to
credentials
and like how you get ahead and the crazy
thing
about money printing is that like
you know people look at that and they
say oh this is terrible
like it's you know my my wealth is going
to be it's going to be inflated away
it's going to be stolen from me and it's
like i think about it
in like sort of redistributive sense
maybe which is like
actually this is awesome because it
means that everything that
can be funded that is profitable that
should make money that helps people
should get funded now and that
definitely wasn't happening like five
years ago
20 years ago or 50 years ago definitely
you go back like hundreds of years
and it's like basically nothing good was
getting funded right it's all about just
like
keeping the social order like basically
completely stagnant
and keeping people where they are i'm
like shoot like
what this means is like amazing stuff
but we can't do it just by
like sort of holding them in one place
like let's actually teach people that
they can create stuff for each other
like there's so many problems out there
to solve
let's solve all of them now like there's
the money for it let's empower people i
find it very interesting
and i thought of two things number one
your point about you don't need a
like college degree from stanford that's
definitely true it's also
more and more true this is what kills me
the ethos of
online education is something i believe
super strongly in
i think it's been kind of been corrupted
by like these predatory courses who
ironically
make fun of how much college costs and
then gouge
prices for their like garbage 16 you
know hour course and they charge you
know three thousand dollars for it
but there are people who are doing it
the right way i interviewed quincy
larson
creator of free code camp and it's like
amazing he's teaching
everybody constantly and he'll give a
free coding education to anyone
absolutely for free no strings attached
and then i thought of something
else because you said you want to create
a community it almost reminds me of like
an online y combinator type thing yeah
of like where y combinator almost in a
way feels
a bit exclusive i was talking to justin
khan and i was like talking to him about
his awesome
yeah he's he's great but but there's
only so many people
y combinator can take and one of the
beautiful things about
um online communities is that they scale
super easily but they're but
i'm actually interested in this how do
you think
online communities fail compared to
real life communities and how do you how
do you want to address that
yeah that's a great question you brought
up y combinator and i just i mean i have
to sort of point out like
actually that's what paul graham did
like i was a software engineer
with credit card debt and i was like
running the rat race working for
microsoft
and then i found paul graham's essays
and he taught me oh shoot like you don't
actually have to have a job like you
weren't meant to have a job
maybe you should start a company well we
are getting into some
some california paul graham ideology i
love it go go go go go go go
but yeah and then basically he made
hacker news which is that
is like you know you look at circle.so
or you look at like a lot of these like
online communities for creators
the hacker news was like the first one i
mean i guess reddit was the first
and then hacker news he started because
the founders of reddit wouldn't give him
uh super moderator access for our
startups on reddit so but you know the
subreddit is an incredibly powerful idea
for like how these communities should
probably work
um but yeah i mean i think we're just
recycling that
because that's actually how yc started
like i didn't i found out about yc
through essays and then being a part of
that community and then
the top thing on hacker news was like
apply to y combinator and then you're
like oh well what is this thing
i was like oh i could do that um and now
that you know they've created
four or five hundred billion dollars
worth of startups since they've existed
they've put out so many incredible
companies and
and i do think it's amazing
how much it's like let's take a great
idea and let's just
iterate on it um and it feels to me like
you're trying to iterate on the same
inspiration that you got
from paul graham and iterate it for a
new generation
yeah i mean go with what i i think
that's the thing there's nothing new
under the sun
there's just what you uniquely can add
and then beyond that a synthesis
right like take stand on the shoulders
of giants
look at what people want and then try to
give it to them really
so one thing i have to ask
is that there is this um
problem that i talk about a lot on my
channel that i want to ask you about
because you're in this sort of business
education space
and i'm super passionate about sort of
uh
this weird phenomenon of
fake gurus fake business coaches who
they've there's this almost um
meta of promising the world to people
and kind of not giving them the goods
yeah
and my question to you is
have you seen this play out and how do
you think we can make
how do you think we can change this for
the better yeah that's a great question
you know there's a reason why this
happens and um
my theory is that um you know even as
youtubers
we have an incredible voice but you know
unfortunately like it or not you and i
um even with the big following we are
under the api so all of the world is
being rewritten with software
people who write the software get to
sort of control things
and then you know the rest of us are
sort of like we're basically like uber
drivers
you know and that's there's it kind of
sucks on the one hand on the other hand
like
you know we can put you know we can
figure out how to get ahead on that
stuff right and it's still
valuable and powerful and so part of
how the um work
you know some of it is organic you and i
spend a lot of time on pure organic
right but there are people out there who
are these fake gurus
who spend a lot of time on paid and
um that's an interesting quirk of the
system
the more money you charge you know
you're and then
startup parlance we talk about it as
lifetime value
so the more a customer who comes in is
worth to you
the more you can then you can take that
money and you put it back in customer
acquisition costs
you blitz scale ads exactly and so
that's what you're seeing
um the really great content does still
rise up it's purely organic
yeah the good and that's the good news
right the good news is that there is
an organic way to understand everything
that you need to know to start a
business and to get ahead in life yeah
right and it's really organic and we're
on that side of you know
we're on that side of the equation right
and then there's another
darker side that requires the people to
enter that side
to charge money and charge a lot of
money and then the
tricky thing that's funny is that like i
actually don't think that they're good
businesses
like if you look at some of the lawsuits
between some of the people
we're talking about i mean we don't have
to name names it's like all of them have
been in lawsuits
all of them like double cross backstab
like hurt each other
and it's like you know what like we fun
i work with a lot of founders i work
with a lot of businesses
and the good founders lawsuits
generally like you can run into one
lawsuit like your entire like 10 years
because like something happened right
but like some of these people it like
seems like there's a lawsuit that like
follows them every single year or like
every six months and it's like
shoot you know these are not good
businesses and like you're not making
enough money and so
you know that's why that stuff happens
right like it's just like
so on the one hand don't hate the player
hate the game like the game
is that people are taking profits but
they're not profits they're actually
they
drop it back into costs and they're
running a treadmill actually
and but what that means is they get way
more distribution a lot more people see
it
and that's what you're sort of pointing
to it's like why are all of these fake
gurus doing this and it's like
i feel empathy and sympathy for them
because they are also under the api
and they have to do it they don't have
another choice
yeah part of me feels like part of me
agrees that it's like not as good of a
business model as people think because
you realize they're spending
they're making 3 million but they're
spending 2.5 on you know
ad adsense you know um
but another part of my issue
is that part of the claims you have to
make to convert
on traffic and because your whole thing
is like bringing costs down
part of it is like the easiest way is
hey man make some more claims like tell
people
you know give them some wild story and
tell them you're gonna change their life
and
make it better and the way i think about
it is we don't allow people to say
hey i've got a cancer curing drug right
because yeah
because it's predatory advertising
because fundamentally anyone sick would
buy that
why do we allow people to sell get rich
quick schemes it's the same thing but
it's for
you know poor people are in desperate
yeah i'm with you they'll do anything
they'll do
anything to get out of their situation
and they're told oh
don't worry about it you just need to
know like these like three little tricks
to get out of it um which is why like
i've railed against it forever but i've
decided that the
one new shift that i've gone towards is
now trying to platform
good voices and show people there's a
better way to do this and there's also
better people to listen to i'm not
telling people to listen to my business
advice
but i will send it to people like your
channel people like justin khan people
like jason calcanis who put out
y'all put out tons of free content
talking about
how to be a real entrepreneur how to you
know each of you guys have done
incredible whether it be through
businesses you've built or
investments you've made um
i guess that's the good news for me is
that i do see more of you guys coming
out there and i'm like
yes tell your other vc friends that they
need to get
so i guess i am glad that you're telling
everyone to get into youtube because i'm
like yes tell
tell them to get involved i'd love to
support their channel if i can
and then the algorithm is going to
support you and support me and like
we'll all get there together actually
which is really cool
so this is interesting the idea
of um algorithms now controlling things
there are obviously really good things
that it's
done it algorithms are kind of
incredible
content discovery mechanisms for new
content
that like doesn't have distribution and
they can just find it
what do you think are some problems we
are seeing
with let's say the if if you have
anything on the youtube algorithm
or social media do you have any thoughts
on that
you know i when i first started and when
you are starting out on youtube
it is hell right it's like you work
really really hard
this stuff is you know really hard to
make and
and then you put it out there and nobody
watches and nobody cares
or you get like a bunch of thumbs down
and it's like you suck
and you're like what this is free this
stuff is free i just you know
why are you doing that man i still don't
understand that why people do that but
um i went to actually i went to casey
and i was like hey casey like what's the
deal with the algorithm this is so not
fair
and then he was like he basically i
think if i was in person he would
probably punch me in the arm or
something and he'd be like
you know what he did say was you have
the wrong attitude
right you know it's the content right
the content is good
i told you get good yeah i mean
don't you're just he's like you're just
wait looking for ways to blame other
people
right and i thought about it and it's
like oh shoot that's right that's
actually like a self-defeating thing
that i see everywhere that i try i try
to actively encourage
you know out of people especially people
who are trying to start companies is
like you're always sort of
the easy way out is to like fail with
style
right the harder thing to do is like
i can crack this there's nothing special
about you know this other person did it
this other person did it if they can do
it i can do it i'm gonna figure it out
and um i think that that's actually that
was useful for me he was like don't
blame the algorithm
everyone does that um you know you just
need to make your thing
awesome just focus on that and that was
like the best advice i could get at that
moment
there's always going to be an algorithm
whether or not it's fair no of course
it's never fair
right but you still gotta play um and
when you play like
you know you still get the the outcome
that you want
right that is an amazing answer i
actually think that might be a great way
to end it today
uh gary is on that note
i think that's an incredible lesson for
people to take away
i know these people one of the things
about content is people's attention span
is tight so um yeah you know it
thank you for having me let me say guys
if you want to go
hear more insights like what you've
heard today i found you so inspiring
so thoughtful if you want to hear more
things like this
go to gary tin's youtube channel um
linked in the description below let's
blow him up
you've already blown up you're fine but
uh if you like what he said
give it a subscribe give it a watch and
congratulations on your future and
um on the coinbase and best of luck with
all your future endeavors i hope you
find
many more like it thanks man you gotta
do this again
for sure sounds good my channel next
time
do it let's do it see you guys
wake up and smell the coffee